Guten Abend. Ich bin Dr. Erbilen. Heute für Sie zuständige Ersten. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Geschiebrecht führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Okay, danke. Zuerst möchte ich ein paar Personen mit der Organe frage stellen, dann können wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden besprechen. Alles normal für Sie?
Ja.
Vielen Dank. Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Gabriele Schmidiskamp.
Gabriele Schmidiskamp. Schön, dass Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen buchen.
Ja, Schmidiskamp schreibt sich S-C-A-M-I-E-D-E-S-K-A-M-P. Schmidiskamp.
Okay, vielen Dank. Frau Schmidiskamp. Wie alt sind Sie?
39.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 16. Dezember 1989.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1983. Entschuldigung, nicht 1983.
83, ja genau. Okay.
Wie groß? 1,70 m.
1,70 m. Okay. Wie viel wegen Sie zur Zeit wissen Sie?
65 kg.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen, Frau Schmidiskamp.
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Seit 3 Tagen fühle ich mich nicht wohl. Ich bin müde und schlapp.
Ich habe Schüttelfrost und habe heute auch Fieber gemessen.
Das war bis 39,4 m im Mund.
Ja, und schön.
Ja, es geht mir nicht gut.
Okay.
Frau Schmidiskamp, ist Ihnen irgendein Auslöser für diese Beschwerden aufgefallen?
Nein, ich habe dafür keine Erklärung.
Sind die Beschwerden plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Ja, ich habe es nicht.
Ich habe gedacht, das geht wieder vorbei, aber es wird eher schlimmer.
Seit 3 Tagen sind alle Beschwerden dauerhaft und in der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Ja, ja.
Ich habe es nicht gemacht.
Das ist dauerhaft und in der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Sind Sie beim anderen Arzt?
Nein, bis jetzt noch nicht.
Okay, Frau Schmidiskamp.
Ja, ähm, leiden Sie unter Herzstrasen oder Herzstolpern?
Nein, nein, Herzstrasen, Herzstolpern, ich glaube, mein Puls ist jetzt etwas höher, aber ich glaube, das hängt mit dem Fieber zusammen.
Ja, genau, genau.
Mhm.
So, ähm, husten Sie?
Nein.
Ja, und ist Ihnen Hautveränderungen aufgefallen?
Ich schwitze nur sehr stark.
So, ähm, ja.
Und, ähm, ja, haben Sie Durchfall oder Verstopfung?
Ja, Durchfall habe ich, äh, Durchfall habe ich jetzt auch seit drei Tagen, so fünf bis sechs Mal am Tag.
Fünf bis sechs am Tag.
Mhm.
So, ähm, wie ist die Stuhl, wie ist das aus der Stuhl?
Der Stuhl ist...
Gibt es Blut oder Verkenderung?
Nein, kein Blut, der ist auch nicht irgendwie schwarz, ja, normale Farbe.
Okay.
Ich habe kein Blut.
Mhm.
Ja, okay.
Ja, und, ähm, haben Sie Bauchschmerzen auch?
Ähm, ich habe so Muskelgelenk und Muskelschmerzen, mir tun die Muskel weh und ein bisschen tut mir der Rücken auch weh.
Ähm, aber Bauchschmerzen direkt nicht.
Ähm, Sie haben auch Gehlengschmerzen gesagt, ja.
Ja.
Herr, ähm, ja, Frau Schmidiskamp, ähm, ähm, waren Sie in der letzten Zeit, äh, im Ausland?
Ja, ich war in Russland so vor fünf Wochen.
Mhm.
Für zwei Wochen, ähm, in Asien.
Da war ich in Thailand und in Vietnam.
Ach, ich verstehe.
Ähm, ja, ähm, damals ist, ähm, ja, ist Ihnen, ähm, eine Mykenstich aufgefallen, Yukrais am Haut.
Mücken, Mückensticher hatten wir alle etwas, äh, aber für mich jetzt nichts Besonderes, aber es gab da Mücken, das stimmt.
Ja, man versucht, vor den Mücken zu schützen, mit Moskitonetzen und äh, so etwas, aber man kann es ja nicht immer verhindern.
Ja, okay, ja, natürlich.
Ja, natürlich.
Ähm, ja, so, haben Sie auch Kopfschmerzen, äh, Frau Schmidiskamp?
Ja, ich habe auch jetzt Kopfschmerzen, das schiebe ich auf das Fieber.
Mhm.
Ähm, ja, Sie, diese Besperr, den, äh, kommt wie anfallsartig oder ja, äh, das Fieber besonders.
Genau.
Gibt es, äh, ja, so, dauerhaft, ja?
Das ist eigentlich dauerhaft.
Mhm, okay.
Ich habe das jetzt noch einmal erst gemessen.
Mhm.
Da war ich doch sehr erschrocken, dass es eben 39,4 war.
Ich glaube, ich habe, ich habe schon seit, jetzt seit drei Tagen habe ich schon Fieber.
Ja, okay, okay, so.
Und äh, Sie sind ähm, vor fünf Wochen äh, nach Deutschland zurückgeflogen, ja?
Ja, vor, also vor vier Wochen bin ich wiedergekommen.
Vor vier.
Ich bin quasi zwei Wochen äh, in Thailand und in, äh, Vietnam.
Mhm, ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Ja, es ist so, ähm, jetzt, ich möchte ein paar Fragen, äh, zu Ihrer ähm, Allgemeinzustand, äh, Stellen.
Ja.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist er gut, aber jetzt seit drei Tagen ist er nicht gut.
Mhm.
Da habe ich keinen Hunger.
Ja, ich verstehe auch.
Ja, ich verstehe. Und hat sich Ihr Gewicht in der letzten Zeit verändert?
Merkli verändert?
Nein, eigentlich habe ich mein Gewicht immer gehalten.
Es kann sein, dass es jetzt vielleicht seit zwei Tagen etwas weniger geworden ist,
jetzt durch Durchfall und so.
Ich habe mich jetzt nicht mehr gewogen.
Aber normal halte ich mein Gewicht immer mit 65 kg.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, etwas schon. Aber ich muss nicht erbrechen.
Etwas übel ist mir auch.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Normalerweise kann ich gut schlafen.
Als ich jetzt diesen Durchfall und das Fieber bekommen habe,
habe ich auch nachts nicht gut geschlafen.
Ja, natürlich.
Okay.
Gibt es Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Zurzeit nicht.
Ich habe früher oft Probleme beim Wasserlassen gehabt.
Da habe ich häufig Handwichsinfekte gehabt und auch Nierenentzündungen.
Okay.
Letzt allerdings vor fünf Jahren war das.
Da musste ich auch längere Zeit ein Antibiotikum nehmen.
Okay, okay.
Ich verstehe.
Aber letzte Attacke für Handwichsinfektionen und Niereninfektionen
vor fünf Jahren.
Ja.
Damals wurden Sie stationär behandelt oder ambulant?
Nein, das war ambulant.
Okay.
Ich verstehe.
Frau Schmidteskamp,
jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte stellen.
Gibt es chronische oder wichtige,
außer diese Handwichsinfektionen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich nehme nur eine, normalerweise eine Medizin,
eine Tablette.
Und das ist für die Schildröse.
Nehm ich morgens eine Tablette.
Moment, wie heißt die?
Eutirox.
Eutirox, so.
75.
Okay.
Morgen ist eine Tablette,
weil ich habe eine vergrößerte Schildröse.
Die hat auch zwei Knoten.
Das Ganze nehme ich jetzt seit drei Jahren.
Es wird jetzt demnächst entschieden werden,
weil sie ist nicht wesentlich kleiner geworden,
die Schildröse.
Operationen.
Das ist nicht so, dass sie nicht geflogen werden muss.
Aber das ist geklärt.
Ich glaube, sie gehen regelmäßig deswegen zum
Endocrinologie abteilen.
Ja, also zu der Schildrösenuntersuchung gehe ich zu
alle anderthalb Jahre.
Das wird aber zwischendurch auch beim Hausarzt kontrolliert.
Das Blut und auch mit Ultraschinen.
Ja, okay.
Ja, außer Eutrox nehmen sie bei Bedarf etwas.
Nein, sonst nehmen sie keine Medikamente.
Okay, sehr gut.
Dann, wo denn sie schon einmal operiert,
Frau Schmiddeska?
Vor langem im Kindesalter.
Da wurde ich operiert am Blindarm.
Da war ich glaube ich 13 Jahre alt.
Und dann wurde ich auch schon an den Mandeln operiert.
Da war ich elf Jahre alt.
Ja, diese beiden Operationen.
War in dieser beiden Operationen Komplikation los, oder?
Ja, das war gut.
Ist Ihnen irgendwann ein,
ein Unfall bekannt oder wurden Sie schon einmal stationär behandelt?
Nein, nein, ich hatte keine Unfälle.
Nein, stationär außer den Operationen war ich noch nie im Krankenhaus.
Ja, okay, alles klar.
Dann sind Sie allergisch auf eine Medikamente
oder gibt es welche Stoppe?
Nein, ich bin nicht allergisch drauf.
Die Antibiotika damals wegen der Nierenbeckenentzündung,
die habe ich immer alle gut vertragen.
Und eine Allergie ist nicht bekannt.
Okay, haben Sie Unfalltätigkeiten, Frau Schmiddeska?
Also ich kann alles essen.
Ich vertrage alles.
Ich esse nicht alles, aber ich glaube, ich vertrage alles.
Okay, alles klar.
Ja, jetzt, ich möchte zu Ihrer Gewohnheit fragen.
Ja, rauchen Sie Frau Schmiddeska?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Also ich trinke vielleicht einmal in der Woche ein Glas Wein,
aber das ist auch nicht regelmäßig.
Also wenn irgendwo vielleicht mal ein gutes Essen ist,
eine Feier ist oder so etwas mit Freunden,
dann trinke ich mal ein Glas Wein,
aber das ist jetzt nicht regelmäßig.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und ja, treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport, Frau Schmiddeska?
Ja, ich spiele etwas Tennis.
Und ich mache Yoga.
Oh, sehr, sehr, super.
Und ja, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, aber ich habe keine Kinder.
Ja, ich verstehe mir gut.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Lehrerin.
Haben Sie Stress auf der Arbeit?
Die Arbeit heute in der Schule ist schon stressig.
Genau.
Aber trotzdem macht mir die Arbeit Spaß.
Ja, na schön.
Ja, trost am Gut.
Und wie ist Ihr Impfstatus, Frau Schmiddeska?
Sind Sie gegen Kinderkrankheit und Corona?
Impfstatus ist gut.
Als ich jetzt nach Asien gereist bin,
habe ich das nochmal alles überprüfen lassen.
Ich habe auch Tabletten genommen gegen Malaria.
Ich musste allerdings, weil ich dort auch mal einen Magendamen-Infekt hatte
für vier Tage die Tabletten aussetzen.
Als ich in Vietnam war,
ja, aber mein Impfstatus ist, glaube ich, gut.
Ja, okay, gut.
Was für Tabletten haben Sie für Proflaxe genommen?
Tabletten heißen Malarone.
Da habe ich einen Tag oder zwei Tage, bevor ich hingeflogen bin,
habe ich damit angefangen und bis zum Tag nach der Reise.
Aber ich musste, wie gesagt, einmal vier Tage aussetzen,
weil da war mir so schlecht und habe ich so viel erbrochen.
Da konnte ich keine Tabletten nehmen.
Die Tablette wurden zweimal pro Tag eingenommen.
Einmal pro Tag.
Einmal pro Tag, okay.
Hatten Sie wegen der Gastroenteritis
vor vier Tagen etwas eingenommen?
Nein, da war ich in Vietnam in einem kleinen Hotel.
Da hatte ich nichts eingenommen, nur Flüssigkeit.
Tee, Wasser.
Dann wurde mir auch gesagt, dass es dann schnell besser wird.
Es wurde dann auch besser.
Aber diese vier Tage waren sehr anstrengend.
Wenn Sie heute die aktuelle Beschwerden vergleichen
mit Gastroenteritis, sind Sie gleich oder unterschiedlich?
Nein, nicht gleich.
Bei der Gastroenteritis musste ich auch stark erbrechen.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht.
Jetzt habe ich zwei Durchfall.
Ich habe jetzt keinen erbrechen.
Hatten Sie damals auch Fieber?
Das kann sein, aber es war sicherlich nicht so hoch wie jetzt.
Ich verstehe.
Frau Schmiderskapp, ich möchte wissen, ob es in Ihrer Familie
wichtige Vorerkrankungen gibt.
Ihre Mutter und Vater.
Mein Vater ist 67 Jahre alt.
Er hatte seit ca. 4 Jahren Blutkrebs.
Wir haben Chemotherapie und Blutübertragung.
Damit geht es ihm einigermaßen.
Er ist geschwächt, aber fühlt sich ganz gut.
Zurzeit ist er stabil.
Er muss immer wieder zu Kontrollen.
Alle vier Wochen wird Blutbild gemacht.
Die Mutter, die 66 Jahre alt,
hatte Brustkrebs.
Da war sie 46.
Sie haben Brustkrebs,
da wurde sie auch behandelt.
Die Kontrollen waren aber jetzt alle in Ordnung.
Sie haben eine Schwester, die 36 Jahre alt,
die hat Asthma.
Ich habe aber nur eine Schwester.
Frau Schmiderskapp,
haben Sie schon einmal wegen der
Mama-Katzenau eine Vorsorge-Untersuchung gemacht?
Die regelmäßig zur Frauenärztin.
Die Frauenärztin hat schon mal Ultraschall gemacht.
Aber bisher war alles so weit.
Und wann war der letzte Periode,
Frau Schmiderskapp?
3 Wochen.
Wie verhütten Sie sich?
Die Verhütungsmittel.
Die Zeit ist bereits vorbei.
Ich bin mit dem Gespräch durch Frau Schmiderskapp.
Haben Sie Fragen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzubeben?
Nein.
Vielen Dank.
Ich werde Ihnen körperlich untersuchen.
Dann abnehmen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind,
werden wir noch mal darüber besprechen.
Sie können im Behandlungsraum gehen.
Ich komme gleich.
Heute haben wir versprochen,
wenn die 20 Minuten sind,
eine Bescheid geben.
Deswegen habe ich Kollegen oder Kollegen
eine andere Frage.
Frau Schmiderskapp, haben Sie Verstopfung?
Nein.
Ich habe eher Durchfall.
Ich habe 5-6 Mal am Tag durchgeführt.
Ich habe nicht mehr durchgeführt.
Ich habe keine Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang.
Ich habe eher Durchfall.
Haben Sie in den 3 Tagen etwas Verdobenes gegessen?
Vor 3 Tagen.
Ich erinnere mich nicht daran.
Da haben wir immer gemeinsam gegessen.
Mein Mann und ich.
Der hat jetzt gar nichts.
Dem geht es gut.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich etwas Verdorbenes gegessen habe.
Aber ich weiß es nicht sicher.
Aber ich glaube es nicht.
Haben die Familienangehörige
oder Arbeitspoende beschwerden?
Nein.
Haben Sie Schluckbeschwerden?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nicht aufgefallen.
Nein.
Danke schön.
Eine Kollegin.
Bitte.
Leiten Sie unter.
Nein.
Ich habe nicht aufgefallen.
Wie leiten Sie unter Schüttelfrost?
Ja.
Ich habe Schüttelfrost.
Ich habe dann Fibre gemessen.
39,4.
Am schlimmsten sind die Muskelschmerzen.
Die Gelenkschmerzen.
Ich glaube, dass ich einen Marathon gelaufen werde.
Und nicht trainiert habe.
Haben Sie schon eine ähnliche Gelenke oder Muskelschmerzen gelitten?
Nein.
Ich denke, wir haben alle Fragen gestellt.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Haben Sie Hautabschlack bemerkt?
Besonders im Bauchbereich?
Nein.
Sie haben schon Fragen gestellt.
Okay.
Könnten wir als Erster zu Beginn beginnen?
Ja.
Erstens.
Ich versuche kein Problem.
Wenn Sie da möchten.
Wir können gerne anfangen.
Erstens.
Ich versuche es.
Ich möchte vorstellen.
Ja.
Sie hat sich bei uns wegen seit 3 Tagen bestehend
der Probedienter Müdigkeit und Schüttelfrost
aufgetretener Fibre vorgestellt.
Außerdem leidet sie an Diarröhe.
Die sich seit 3 Tagen bestehender
und 5-6 Mal täglich äußert.
Sie machte vor 5 Wochen Urlaub in den Tropischen Land
und kam vor 4 Wochen zurück.
Dann sind der Patienter von der Beglei Symptom aufgefallen.
Allgemein mialgi, atralgi, hyperhydroze
Takyokardi.
Aufgesilte Fragen,
Fernandes, noizia, emesis, düssfagis,
notasis.
Okay. Gut. Das ist gut, oder? Ja, ja.
Das sind die beiden.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberratz. Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen, die ich Ihnen gerne vorstellen möchte. Hätten Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, habe ich.
Vielen Dank. Es geht um Gabriele Schmideskamp. Sie ist 39 Jahre alt, 1,75 m groß, 65 schwer.
Frau Gabriele Schmideskamp hat sich bei uns wegen seit 3 Tagen langsam aufgetretene, bestehende, dauerhafte, progrediente Müdigkeit,
Schutteilfrost und Fieber vorgestellt. Das Fieber wurde im Mund als 39,4 Grad gemessen.
Sie außer dem HB sie auch Schutteilfrost und Hyperhidrosis.
Sie hat auf Antimallarial-Tablete angefangen. Aber sie hat in Thailand für 4 Tage eine Gastroenteritis bekommen.
Deswegen hat sie Antimallarial-Tablete abgesetzt.
Für diese Zeit nur? Ja, für diese Zeit.
Dann wegen der Stärke erbrechen.
Hat die Patientin einen normalen Stuhlgang oder hat sie auffällig?
Ja, das ist auffällig. Sie hat die Diarröhe pro Tag 5-6 Malig, die Sahe wässrig aus, keine Blutbeidemischung bemerkt.
Als Begleitsyntome klackte sie über die Diffuse mühalgien und Rückenschmerz sind artralgien.
Die vegetative Anamnese sei unhaffällig bis auf beschwerde Bedingte in Appetenz und Schlafstörungen.
An der Rückkrankung leidet sie an Schütterung, Nodosa und seit 3 Jahren dagegen eine Näme sich regelmäßig über 75 Mikrogramm Tablete einmal morgens.
Es gibt eine Möglichkeit, um diese Knoten zu operieren.
Sie hatte auch vor 5 Jahren redetive Handwerksinfektionen und Nierensteine.
Sie hatte die letzten Attacke vor 5 Jahren und sie hatte damals längere Antibiotik, Antibiozyttherapie eingenommen.
Sie hat in der Vorgeschichte rezidivierte Handwerksinfekte mit Pyolo-Nifritiden zuletzt vor 5 Jahren.
Es wurde bei ihr mit Älteren eine Tonselektomie durchgeführt.
Die allergen Anamnese sei unhaffällig, die Nuxen Anamnese auch unhaffällig.
Sie ist verheiratet, aber keine Kinder. Als Beruf ist sie Lehrerin.
Die Familienanamnese ergab eine
Bluttransfusion.
Die erste Diagnose war im Alter von 46.
Sie wurde operiert behandelt.
Sie hat eine gute Zustand.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Sie hat eine gute Anamnese.
Was kommt differenzialdiagnostisch in Betracht?
Sie hat auch Rückenschmerzen.
Sie hat auch eine vorgeschichte.
Sie hat eine gute Anamnese.